it's Tuesday you know what that means
its own Australis time the Oscars might
[Music]
shout out patron at the day shadow for
dagger shy does today
[Music]
it's time once again for the Oscars
Hollywood's a New York show for the best
films released between I was in favor in
late December these nominees will win
the coveted title of best picture unless
the guy charged the resource cursor
because he was on his phone backstage
and they accidentally give it to someone
else
this is not a joke move I did won best
picture or your nominees you see in
Dunkirk spread his portrayal of heroism
in the face of death now prepare for a
movie about all the talking it was going
on I get ready to see Gary Oldman acting
like you've never seen him before
in a fat suit hey October that actually
to win an Oscar over eating a bison
liver or something really bad like being
Casey Affleck the old man from visionary
director yes when is essentially
obligated to be credited as visionary
director comes a love story between a
woman and the fish prisoner in her lab
which sounds creepy when used to be
lured away from it but trust me in the
context of the story you will totally be
okay with this woman having sex with a
fish man
it's actually a really beautiful story
as your voice and man this is gonna be
known as the fish banging movie isn't it
[Music]
said during the great Italian shirt
shortage ever I get married that's a
touching new beds between this grown man
and the 17 year old which also sounds
creepy which Easter Parade ended in this
field full of cinematography moving
performances and groundbreaking visual
effects that removed army hammers balls
from a short swords
and one of the most mesmerizing films at
the Farmers Association is saying that's
not what he brought them but hey you do
you know he trained me most likely I
think he's gonna wear Lady Justice the
only way she knows how local advertising
Evalia with such powerful performances
you'll stop referring to Sam Rockwell as
that guy and start referring to him as
that guy you know from three billboard
[Laughter]
the last week it's guy Dan no witness
Daniel day-lewis is stunning farewell
performance as an obsessed craftsman who
has trouble separating his art from his
personal life so some actor you've
definitely pretended to know about
already comes a known perfect
coming-of-age story how about the most
difficult challenge a teenager can face
having to grow up in Sacramento was such
a tough time navigating her friendships
boy friends and family you'll almost
forgive her for defending crash by the
Dave Matthews Band
[Music]
Who am I to talk Oh Papa Roach in high
school put a bird come on I read two
pieces of the best director of all time
according to every numbers online so
clinically and so equally out of
sequence by Christopher Nolan everything
has to be a puzzle box Chris saving lots
of privates mr. oh not me a lot more
than about a light so today the Academy
Award winner Tom Hanks at 21 time
Academy Award nominee bear oh really -
town movie about the media resisting an
unpopular Republican president in a film
so calculated to win Oscars they may as
well just quit Academy Award nominee in
the title and academia Award nominated
opposed the teachers Awards to the
Academy Awards comes the directing debut
of the player formerly known as mascot
and a bar thriller that holds a mirror
up to smug affluent white progressives
in other words starring the bali comic
book movies the nerds think we're stuck
in the categories they should have been
known in for thor ragnarok for best go
blue Wonder Woman for best two-thirds of
the movie for Best Picture but only the
son of God
broken for Best Picture for people who
only sell comic book movies last year
guardians - for best movie you enjoyed
that immediately forgot about spider-man
homecoming for best lack of an origin
story and guardians for best Russian
superhero movie I only saw a trailer for
but at least one of the turns into a
bear and I missed this one however that
you actually
[Music]
man with all the sexual harassment
exposed this year this is gonna be a
really sensitive emotional ceremony
take it away those two the Maine Shore
[Applause]
elongated muskrat
my mom has a cat to tend to mean H&V
Totti dolls
mm HS the VH best buy the Batman I'm the
Birdman
[Music]
[Music]
wow that's honest trailers differs from
last year's Oscars honest trailers
because I've seen eight out of nine of
these movie the only one I missed was
phantom thread I think I should try to
watch that this week my pick that I'm
hoping will woman would be the shape of
water for my heart it would be out of
you that or get out yeah sentimentally
speaking of course I love all the jokes
they had here with the joke titles they
called darkest hour grumpy old I didn't
know that thing about armie hammer
having a CGI out his nutsack that's so
crazy to me it's just a year where they
had to edit out body parts hey man he's
joining the club Jon Hamm had his bulb
cg doubt in various episodes of madman
why can't our me hammer do it here
that's true I find a fine a timothy
Shalom a is a start call me by your name
you also as a supporting role in Lady
Bird and Michael Stuhlbarg is in the
post like every call movie name in shape
of water man they don't point that out
though I don't think enough people are
pointing that out a man stole bark is
killing the game there's like some of
the biggest movies of the year and no
one recognizes that that's what you get
when you're that guy I think my favorite
joke title had to be three racist inside
every Missouri I don't know how I feel
about the fathom the disaster artist was
not nominated I mean they had this
ending joke about Jimmy Kimmel from the
man show but very dude Lee is very like
coming out of the man shows yeah it's
not the locust position to be an hour
coming in to host the Oscars at a time
like this I know that everything with
James Franco it call
not to get nominated and not like force
no no statement was released on this but
there is that cited me just like was
died yeah I mean if Casey Affleck was
able to win last year course-correcting
for the Oscars to make themselves look
good oh yeah they're definitely I don't
think it's right at all what James
Franco did I don't think the Casey
Affleck thing happened before we really
got serious about it and also that
situation arose kind of amidst the the
race it felt like anyway yeah and now I
don't think they can at that point I'm
sure they could ride this sort of like
well the ball was already rolling I
don't know but now you you can't really
do that whatever he's won a bunch of
awards already anyway James Franco yeah
I mean that's a totally bummers
situation cuz just as a movie I really
appreciate it's one of the ones that
stuck with me more from last year and
especially looking over these again like
Dunkirk is a movie that the more we've
gotten close to the Oscars the more I
realize just how much that movie stuck
with me and so I was kind of taken aback
there touched on it so so quickly here
it's kind of like Dunkirk and we're
moving on so you can't really touch on
dunker too much there's not much to
really go off it's more of a technical
well made film but because they make fun
of like the characters a lot in the
other ones and they're always not really
character to make fun of in there yeah
other than Harry style Harry Styles yeah
but no I mean this was a fun honest
trailer I hear Thor Ragnarok might be on
its way soon but Diego Chaidez my friend
you are the last patron of the day shout
out for the month of February buddy it's
been a while since we had a Google
hangout we missed your lovely face how
was prom did you go to prom array or did
you not go to prom bells did you get
drunk at prom did you make out with the
girl in the back seat of a limo did you
lose your virginity put it in the
comment boxes below because we all need
to know if we're legit attea yeah did
you get taken find it my virginity a
couple hours away from LA dude if you
ever want to come hang out with us or
say hi to us in person we will gladly
ignore you ringing the doorbell yeah
anytime you want yeah come knock you
might he'll hear us whispering go don't
answer the door comes
see if a neighbor lets you in out of
kindness yeah and then out of guilt will
let you come in for a few hours yeah it
will start off with John and I going
just like 10 minutes
yeah but then we'll feel really bad and
we don't know how to get you to go and
it'll be like two solid hours but it'll
be worth your time you'll think we're
best friends by the end this master you
diego's seriously if you ever want to
come down to LA and come on the channel
let us go
you're really great-looking dude he's 18
charming oh yeah yes sexy just a problem
yeah all right guys well you can
subscribe to screen junkies subscribe to
the real rejects click that notification
milligan notified every time one of our
vids is up and check us out on patreon
fold like TV show reactions and music
videos over there as well as weekly Q&A
is iishe